retour gagnant pour gribouille tout le
caricaturiste et à nouveau à saint
quentin en yvelines pour croquer les
usagers des médiathèques
cette fois il a taillé ses crayons à
trappes il faut pas que la caricature
sur méchant points moi j'ai un très
justement bd pour ça reste relativement
sympa et puis que les gens soient pas
vexer quoi je pense que c'est un métier
qui me convient parce que c'est
il ya la notion de sa maison en
travaillant et ça c'est important pour
moi de
de travailler en est pas en n'ayant pas
l'impression de travailler quoi quelques
traits de feutre et le visage apparaît
petits et grands se sont laissés observé
j'aime le trait je trouve que c'est
quelque chose qui voilà qui me détend il
est super on dirait maintenant c'est
l'humour qui en ressort c'est est-ce que
ça dégage comme comme joie comme joueur
et puis voilà le côté oui humour qui me
plaît
cette nouvelle rencontre avec le public
était organisée par l'agglomération dans
le cadre de beule sky le festival de la
bd
on est vraiment dans l'activité loisirs
d on a donc des rencontres des ateliers
voilà grill vous tous inscrits dans
cette série de rencontres festives
ludiques c'est l'aspect dirai tout
public de la bande dessinée gribouille
tous n'en a pas fini de croquer les
saint quentinois
prochain rendez vous le samedi 28
janvier à voisins le bretonneux
préparez votre meilleur profil